a world where freedom is history in a
world without gas in a world that's
powered by violence these days people
get just as excited for a movie trailer
as they do the actual movie I brought a
clip like a preview trailers can make or
break a film and they even have their
own award show they almost become their
own entertainment form that's Matt
Brubaker CEO of trailer park in LA his
company is responsible for some of the
biggest film trailers in the past few
years including Wonder Woman baby driver
I'm a driver
and Mad Max which won a golden trailer
awards for Best Original trailer so what
goes into an award winning trailer
oftentimes their trailers are started
while filming this is being done the
entire process can take anywhere from
two weeks to two years the earlier the
better
so they can be ready for hyped up events
like comic-con so when we started
trailer we get the direction call from
the studio then we have a creative
meeting internally there's 10 to 15
people I've working on on one project
this includes editors assistant editors
coordinators writers composers and a
creative director on big projects
sometimes up to six different companies
could all be contracted to work on a
film some features we start with dailies
which are you know are the daily of
footage that filmmaker shoots and since
the movie is still being shot some of
this footage might never even appear in
the actual movie sometimes we're working
with things that don't end up in the
final feature and vice-versa
it's not that we're trying to trick the
viewer it's more of like we're having to
tell the story in two and half minutes
not in three hours
there are usually restrictions on what
can be revealed in a trailer oftentimes
there's a plan in place to gradually
reveal plot points and characters
through different campaigns like when it
comes to high-security movies like
Marvel movies
you know we it's part of the creative
directive of what we can show what we
can show with like the movies like The
Avengers and other like Marvel campaigns
there might be three or four trailer
campaigns
and the whole process is on lockdown to
prevent leaks it's like Fort Knox
there's cameras everywhere there's like
you know you can't have internet at your
workstation for edit Bay's everything is
a fireable offense and the MPA is put in
effect very strict policy of how we
handle materials Star Wars a billion
years in the making and it's coming to
your galaxy this summer movie trailers
have evolved a lot over the years one
trick that used to be very common is
quick cuts there was a time where quick
cutting might represent a lot of energy
in action now I think that a lot of
people want to hear or story want to
know like and see that the movie
actually stands on its own these days
you're likely to see more dialog and
plot details in a movie trailer you've
also probably noticed more teasers which
are basically a trailer to a trailer
teasers tease the concept of a movie
while showing very little footage the
social network had a great teaser Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo had a great
teaser it was something that wetted the
audience appetite music is also key to a
good trailer
[Music]
he looks heroic but negative attitude I
think music and sound design is always
important and I think having to be more
unique and special to a property is
involved trailer park has two internal
composers who create music for the
trailers there's a trend now for like
taking old cues and redoing them and we
do that a lot and customize the cues for
for trailers there can be many different
versions of a trailer before the final
one is released one trailer can go
through hundreds of different versions
of edits we've had trailers go through
past version like two hundred generally
it's the studio who gets the the final
sign-off and with so many people sharing
these videos on social media a trailer
is crucial to a film's box-office
success really the first time the studio
and the world sees anything is through
the trailer and it's increasingly more
important and there's such a focus in
such a magnifying glass to what we do so
some studios will focus group the
trailers to make sure they work if you
see a trailer that goes out that is just
mixed movie it looked questionable it's
deadly for the property to overcome that
it's a creative process so sometimes the
best idea is coming you know when you're
taking a shower you are driving